aegon landed at the mouth of the
Blackwater River and raised A Primitive
aegon fort in the disputed land between
haren's and argilac Kingdom so that
neither could decide whose problem he
was adopting the customs of the Seven
Kingdoms aegon unfurled his own Banner
with a red three-headed dragon breathing
fire upon a black field viena crowned
him with a ruby studded circlet of
valarian Steel while reers hailed him as
the first High King the continent had
seen since the born age as his Lords and
the gathered locals cheered him Aon
named his loyal friend to a small
Council led by orus Baratheon whom he
called my strong right hand the title
stuck and abast became the first hand of
the
king but for now aon's Kingdom contained
only a Rocky island and a handful of
fields the other kings had larger armies
ships castles and thousands of years of
rule but Aon had dragons he had chosen
for the words of his house fire and
blood before he was done the rivers
fields and skies would turn
red soon after his coronation Aon
returned to the mouth of the Blackwater
River where he had first set foot on
Westeros a small town had since sprouted
around his primitive for to honor their
new master the locals dubbed it King's
Landing for free you can now listen to
the entire Audi book Fire and Blood On
which house of the Dragon is based and
which covers the entire targaryan
history including current and future
events of House of the Dragon for free
with a notable trial using our Link in
the
description though it looked more fit
for a hedge night with wooden Palisades
muddy streets and piles of mangled
swords carted in from every corner of
the
conquest but when Aon made it his court
wood became became Stone black mud was
buried beneath a red keep and the
collected swords of aon's foes were
blasted by dragon fire and became a seat
fit for the Conqueror and the greatest
Dynasty this world has ever known House
Targaryen King's Landing is both a city
and a curse aegon the Conqueror was the
first king to land there his first
Conquest a tiny village at the mouth of
the Blackwater River was where he raised
a wooden fort when it became clear that
aegon would earn his title people
flocked to the fort and renamed it
King's Landing in his honor the ploy
succeeded and aegon chose King's Landing
for his Capital over older and More
Beautiful cities like Oldtown and
anywhere else the carrying of Royal
favor thus became the foundation of the
city and blood its bricks meor the cruel
aegon son completed the city's famous
red keep to hold the trappings of power
the royal family the King's Guard and
the Iron Throne to maintain the New
Castle Secrets Mega murdered all its
Masons and Craftsmen at a feast which he
catered with the New Castle servants who
soon found all its secrets for
themselves when the faith militant
challenged his rule magor raised their
sep of remembrance to the ground with
them inside at prayer and erected the
dragon pit on the ashes Prince magar a
warrior who was proud and arrogant magar
agreed to marry the high septon niece to
unite the faith and the crown but then
secretly we a second wife in valarian
ceremony artfully combining bigamy and
heresy and when word of it got out the
King was forced to Exile megor and
choose a septin as his new hand but the
damage had been done the king had
trusted in family and his brother had
set off a rebellion that would claim his
rule Rule and his life when agon's Heir
we his daughter to his son the faith
could Brook such Abomination no longer
the high septon led the denunciation of
the tarians and all over wus the faith
militant took up their swords against
the Dynasty and its
supporters the faith militant set upon
and punished the septon who had
performed the ceremony a few of the
faith militants more militant members
even scaled the walls of the castle and
would have slain the king and his family
had a knight of the King's Guard not
intervened frightened the king fled to
Dragonstone where he soon died of
cramps and so ascended the king's
younger brother magor the cruel his
First Act was to challenge the faith
militant to kill him if they believed
his rule to be ungodly to the order's
Eternal credit they accepted
s Damon Morgan proposed a trial by seven
s Damon and six of the faith militant
against the king and his six Champions
it was a contest in which the kingdom
itself was at stake and the accounts and
tales are many but at the end of it
magor alone lived proving that the
throne was rightfully his he mounted the
black dragon valaran and burnt down the
set in King's Landing while the faith
militant were inside at morning prayers
the screams of the burning and dying men
were said to Echo throughout the city
though Mega had won the trial by seven
he demanded the complete destruction of
the faith militant and the faith itself
if necessary he made War upon the order
wherever he found it yet the faith
militant would not surrender raising
armies of their own and turning mea's
own Lords against him the father's
Justice may not always be swift but it
is certain one morning Mega was found
dead on the Iron
Throne no one knows how magor's cruelty
died with him his successor saw the
wisdom of a United crown and faith and
his hand reached an accord with the high
septon as long as the Iron Throne
defended the faith the faith would put
aside its own swords and its
condemnation of the
targaryens the dance of the Dragons a
stupid name for a targaryan civil war
where my ancestors danced away my
Birthright before the war house
targaryan counted 18 Dragons by the end
we had two and nearly as few targaryens
we would never be as powerful or as
feared again the dance began as many
dancers do with an old man and a young
girl the queen had failed to produce a
son for her King so he anointed his
daughter the princess rira as his Heir
but years later the king remarried and
his new wife queen alicent of house high
tower gave him a son feeble and foolish
the Old King refused to change the
succession he didn't even see how his
court had split into two rival camps of
blacks and greens after the dresses of
The Princess and the queen had worn to
some
tny one night a servant found the Old
King had died in his sleep and ran to
inform Queen
alicent protocol dictated that the bells
would be rung and a raven sent to
Dragonstone to summon the air princess
reera for her coronation but Allison had
other plans none were more surprised to
hear of Prince aon's succession than
Prince Aon himself at first the fool
rejected the crown but his mother
pointed out that his sister rira would
return such loyalty by taking his head
as the old King's trueborn son he'd
always be a threat Aon relented he was
CR ground in the dragon pit and his wife
and sister Helena became Queen his
brother Aon flew off to win over the few
great Lords who support Aon didn't
already have the banner of the Gold
Dragon flew over King's Landing and the
red keep as Aon second of his name
ascended the Iron
Throne he would not sit it
long one day King's Landing looked up
and saw two dragons circling their foul
City Damon and rira had come for her
throne for the city was defenseless Aon
had taken the king's Army from the city
and worse he'd taken his Dragon
vagar seeing that resistance was
hopeless the small Council surrendered
the city the queen mother alicent and
the broken Queen Helena but not King
Aon somehow despite his wounds and
delirium he had vanished from the city
and so Queen rira climbed the steps and
seated herself on the Iron Throne Legend
has it that as she left the hall later
blood trickled down her legs and hands
proving the Iron Throne had spurned her
nonsense it's a chair made of steel
blades rira had wanted it all her life
and had sacrificed two sons for it she
likely gripped the damn thing too
tight when renea's last son W aon's only
daughter the dance of dragons officially
ended
passion burned men all that was left of
the
revalence two scared children spouting
oath they didn't understand all that was
left of the mighty House
Targaryen ancient skulls and hatchlings
That Grew no bigger than cats all that
was left of the dragons to Steward his
Monument of vanity bayor summoned the
high sepon of the Faith from his ancient
seed in Oldtown and gifted him with
ornate robes and a crown of Crystal and
gold like a fool the high septon put on
his Lords motly and danced at his Lord's
table and with each passing year the
high sepon fell ever
lower how can the flock be kept safe
from wolves when the shepherd sleeps in
their den Baylor himself appointed a
simple-minded stonemason believing him
the Smith
born and when he died Baylor replaced
him with an 8-year-old boy whom bayor
had seen speaking with doves that
answered with the voices of the
seven still the Common People rever
Balor as the
Blessed they tell of how he forced a
high Lord to wash a Beggar's feet fasted
to tame his unnatural lusts and walked
the boneway himself to make peace with
dor many sept and and scepter even claim
that Balor rescued his cousin the dragon
knight from a snake pit because no Viper
would strike a man so pure and
holy a lie bayor Was Bitten a dozen
times and was bedridden for half a year
and yet he didn't die when the last
dragon died it was only a matter of time
before the tarians
followed by only you mean another
century
which they wasted trying to replace
their lost Advantage incinerating their
own palaces to hatch dragon eggs
drinking Wildfire to become dragons and
let's not forget the Mad King's favorite
burning men alive so he could pretend to
be a
dragon king Slayer a word every man and
woman in westero spits at me though many
can't even name the king I slayed I
understand to them I'm a symbol of
everything they'll never have and a
warning that'll never apply so they can
loathe me from the safety of their small
lives but when a dog goes mad we put it
down why not a king served the king's
pleasure as he burned R star alive and
strangled his son inciting the Rebellion
I defended the king's honor against
cordus as his generals lost battle after
battle with Robert I kept the king
Secrets when his pyromancers and Cashers
at Wildfire beneath King's Landing I
gave the king Council when my father's
Army was at the citygate and Grand maer
pyel lied that my father had come to
save him many forget that I also tried
to defend the king from harm when the
lanister soldiers poured through the
gates it fell to me to hold the red keep
as the only King's God in the city I
knew we were lost and sent to Aries
asking his leave to make terms my man
came back with a royal command bring me
your father's head if you were no
traitor Aries would have no yielding as
pyromancer was with him my messenger
said I knew what that meant AR's
Targaryen was alone in his throne room
when I found him picking at his scapp
and bleeding hands the fool was always
cutting himself in the Iron Throne burn
them burn them he kept
muttering Aries had decided to let
Robert be king after all over the
charred bones and Ashes of King's
Landing he must have thought his
pyromancer was near enough to obey him
but I'd killed him a few minutes before
in the courtyard as I approached the
throne sanity flashed behind the king's
eyes for a moment just long enough to
read the look in mine his eyes grew huge
and the Royal mouth drooped open in
shock he turned and
ran a single thrust was all it took to
end the greatest Dynasty the world had
ever
seen beneath the empty eyes of the dead
dragons on the walls The Last Dragon
King squealed like a pig and shat
himself so easy I thought
a king should die harder than
[Music]
this